dan Patrick show brought to you by
mercedes-benz driver's seat the 2018
mercedes-benz e-class with a suite of
innovative technologies it's one of the
most intelligent cars on the road go to
MBUSA dot-com or visit your local
dealership to schedule your test drive
today
he is america's guest he is South
Korea's guest the former NASCAR driver
now NBC Winter Olympics correspondent
Dale Earnhardt jr. what exactly is your
role at the Olympics the one thing that
I keep hearing is fish had water so
similar to what I was doing at the Super
Bowl with you guys
I go and experience something new and we
try to catch my reactions and my
thoughts and basically we're running
around and seeing a lot of events and by
the end of the week before the closing
ceremony we'll try to capture some of my
oppressions and see if that's TV magic
or not
what is your what's your highlight so
far the highlight of the trip has been
what I got a chance to there's been I
mean this is my first Olympics but
there's everything is overwhelming and
everything is just extreme visually and
just I was it's hard to pick one thing I
got a chance today to interview the
pilots from the four-man bobsled teams
and I really learned a lot I think we're
gonna put a little piece together and I
hope that everybody gets to see that
because I thought that was it was really
educational I just started learn so much
about what they're doing and there's a
lot more to it than you think and
there's a lot of comparisons to racing
it's fast car I've been a voiceover for
another spot that has some connection to
the military bases here which I'm very
happy that I was able to do and I think
people are gonna like that
the short-track speedskating that we saw
tonight is something that I've been
tuned into since the Olympics started
this
here last several weeks
it's like Bristol you know it's like
NASCAR all nice and its aggressive and
can be catastrophic and and there's just
a lot going on there but it's fun and
it's really really popular here in South
Korea so the arena is full of energy and
it's like a sport an event any a
sporting event
popular sport or method you'd you'd
you'd go to back home there's a lot of
energy and the crowds really into what
they're seeing so that makes it a lot of
fun and actually one last thing we saw
the women's u.s. hockey team win gold
today that was so there were so many
emotions in that arena with the
Canadians losing they were sad that was
it was hard to you know your heart went
out to them and then you know America
pulling through and and winning on a
shootout that was really dramatic and it
was just something witness I couldn't
believe that I actually was there to see
it in person you get recognized in South
Korea just by a couple people that are
there you know there's not that many
people over here to know who I am I'm
I'm afraid wait but that could be a good
thing admit yeah I mean I've it's it's
nice to be anonymous I suppose walking
down the street and yeah I mean it's uh
it's it's okay what's the sport would
you that you would like to try you might
be good at I think you know the one that
relates closely for me is bobsledding
when I was a little kid watching the
Olympics I always gravitated toward the
bobsled because it's a you know it's
mimic you're driving something you're in
a you're in a you're in some sort of
vehicle and I learned today that there's
a lot of comparisons to how they
actually train and have to set the sled
up I mean it's as important that they're
in shape and able to do what they do as
a team together it's as important that
the sled handles the track well and the
track
the track surface can be different and
that would require them to adjust and
tune the slid a lot of the guys that are
actually have crew chiefs and mechanics
so the crew chiefs actually have come
from NASCAR backgrounds one of the guys
that I met today worked at Penske on the
IndyCar side another guy that I met
today that actually knew my grandfather
Robert G that worked in NASCAR so it's
pretty interesting I think that that's
where I would probably fit in the most I
certainly don't have the build for it
those guys are huge and they're pushing
a lot of power to get that sled moving
at the start and that would be that
would be somewhere where else it's all
pretty short but otherwise I don't know
I think that I'd be fun to try to drive
one I've talked to Nick one of the
pilots about coming up the Salt Lake
City Inn or Lake Placid and getting a
run in and actually figured out how to
do that you got four years for the next
Winter Olympics that's enough time for
you Junior you're retired put on a
little extra weight you're ready to go
well you know you can always hope and
dream I'm probably I'm probably I'm
probably gonna go up there and try it
and I'll let you know how how I do we're
talking to Dale jr. as he's of course
the former NASCAR Drive it's weird just
say that former NASCAR driver is it
weird for you to hear that yeah it's
pretty weird I mean it's a feel pretty
move into the transition I keep saying I
say transition because I came out of
better words before but a lot of people
say hey how's retirement and I'm getting
used to saying I'm back to work and I'm
just really kind of diving into this new
challenge of working with NBC and it's
uh I don't really know much about
broadcasting and I don't really have a
background like I have a background in
racing it's such a new world for me and
there's a lot to grasp and a lot it
keeps your mind busy and I think that
helps me not think about racing or miss
racing as much and MBC's worked me a lot
since I you know we went to the Super
Bowl we're here
in South Korea so I've had a whole lot
time to sit down and think and I'm not
had a whole lot of time to be bored and
let my mind run so it's uh I went to the
Daytona 500 to do the Grand Marshal and
give the command and I had a great time
I mean I really enjoyed being there I
didn't really miss being in the race it
was fun to watch it it was fun to be a
fan I always say and I don't know if
people really understand what this means
but always say that I was a fan first
before I ever became a driver I was
going to the races watching like dad
pulling for him pulling for other people
so it was not as hard as I thought I
sort of moved back into that role of
just being a fan of what you know what I
love about racing how strange was it to
see that number three take the checkered
flag it's not that strange for me
because I know the family really well I
don't know why people have such a hard
time connecting Austin to Richard and
how he's part of the you know that's his
family team for me it just makes a lot
of sense and I was proud for Austin I'm
proud I'm the person I mean on a from a
from an emotional standpoint I'm happy
for Richard because I know what dad
meant to him and I know how that makes
him feel to see the 3 car has success or
CR CR has success
he misses dad terribly and I know that
that was a pretty neat deal for him but
the other side of me sees the future and
Austin and what often means that team as
a driver and and how he's going to carry
that company forward it's his family
company I mean this is a you know this
is not people act like this is so
uncommon but you know a lot of lot of
drivers got their jobs or got their
starts through family and and I was one
of them as well
but it's it was a great result I was I
was pretty pretty happy with Austin's
got this weird style too you know he's
got this kind of he's different as far
as what he likes and how he portrays
himself
and Hallie brands itself on social media
and I think that that's good for our
sport I really did he's very agile out
of color and so I told him we won I said
you know you're gonna have more fun
celebrating this as you go through all
the media that you have to do after this
win and just do you be you and he is you
know he went but he were doing good Good
Morning America or something like that
when a plaid he's just you know he's
just him and I like I think that we need
that yeah a lot of color you mean you
need personalities have you had any good
food over there in South Korea barbecue
well we did go to the Korean barbecue
and it's not you know I knew it wasn't
like American barbecue because I've been
talking to bro Rutledge the whole time
he's been here and seeing some of the
social media stuff that he posted the
Korean barbecue is pretty fun it's
pretty straightforward you just get a
lot of meat you throw it on this grill
and you're you know there's not you know
there's not a lot of you know seasoning
or marinade or anything like that it's
just meat straight up but there's a I'm
definitely I haven't had any Western
food since I've been here so I've been
trying to learn as much about the
cuisine as I am trying to learn about
the culture and everything else
everybody here SuperDuper nice I'll say
that about Korea they are they're really
really polite people and so that makes
it a great time all right well have fun
in your remaining days there and then
when you get back we'll touch base all
I'll call you and we'll talk do you
think that when I come home I'm gonna
set up a trip Salt Lake City a ride and
will them bobsled you think you want to
take a trip down the down the track with
me I mean there's four seats in that
thing and I think that mmm they'll give
us a driver and a break man I mean you
can have the second third seat that
sounds like a great plan okay
are my arms around you are your arms
around me how about we flip a coin okay
all right that's the deal
okay I'm out I'm all-in do it Thank You
Junior all right have fun safe travels
all right former NASCAR driver Dale jr.
NBC Winter Olympics correspondent for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]